a lot has happened in your life between
the album's what did you want to say
with this one specifically
I just wanted no one to have any doubt
where I want to go in country music I
know this sounds funny but I want to be
the country artists of our generation
female wise nice I want to be the purist
I want to be a Grand Ole Opry member I
want ACM CMAs and I just like this album
really is the flagship to put in the
ground of nobody ever questioning who
out where I'm going
[Music]
you're known for some of your beautiful
I don't even want to call them sad songs
because they're thoughtful and they're
romantic and they make you feel things
[Applause]
[Music]
is it harder for you to write songs in
that vein when you're just so darn happy
right now and in such a good place I am
more sad spirited than I am happy and
it's not that I'm marking around
depressed I just I gravitate towards sad
music I'm able to tap into being sad
easier in a creative sense I think
that's why my biggest songs are sad I
just that emotion for me is easier to go
to
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you collaborated with your husband
Michael ray on finish your sentences
what was that like
[Music]
I knew that he had to be a part of this
record and I am just so happy that we
found the perfect song Kelsea Ballerini
and Thomas Wright actually wrote this
song and once we were engaged because at
first we got sent this song when we were
dating and I was like oh my gosh well we
have to make sure we're gonna stay
together we like make a song together
but when we were engaged I just really
felt like this particular song and what
it said in just the sentiment if it will
have our moments to sing the Tim and
faith it's your love yes like I'm in
love yeah but what was happening during
the making of this record was that we
were falling in love and we were having
fun and doing all those things and this
song really so it was that hot that
moment for me would you ever see
yourself touring together and doing that
sort of synergy I would love that
and I think that we will I think in time
I think we're both just as Tim and Faith
we're kind of at the beginning of our
careers and we're in the building stages
and so we really want to build our
voices outside of each other and then
come together when the time's right
[Applause]
is the concert closed
right after one gets married at least I
know when I did it was so when are you
having a baby oh yeah right so how fast
did you get that question before we were
married did you yeah yeah I you know
it'll come I think again one of the
downsides of both being artists is how
do you do that together he's definitely
very involved in our life together and I
know that he would not like it very much
if I had a child out on the road by
myself yeah I would not like that yeah
so I think the touring aspect and
hopefully we can start to slow down in
the next few years and and be able to
kind of create our own schedules and
figure that out but we want a family
[Music]
you
[Music]